bella tutti ragazzi benvenute questo
video sono parigino ci siamo tolti su
the sims 4 come gli avevo promesso
finalmente creato la famiglia sabrina
sasha che sono qui dentro la chiavetta
tra preso il cognome di sabrina la
famiglia non so perché cereseto e hanno
creato anche steve fair e che sono nella
storia della casa di fianco che la
famiglia to players li ho fatti
veramente bene questo è fare questo e
stef dai sono uguali sono stato
bravissimo ma anche la famiglia di
sabrina è incredibile perché c'è un
miliardo di gatti ad in partenza sabrina
che ragazzi uguale è uguale sabrina l'ho
fatto uguale sono un fenomeno
e poi c'è sasha ragazzi io mi sono come
vi ho detto messo some in casa e
finalmente possiamo giocare con le
famiglie al completo let's go mamma mia
che ho ingaggiato e finalmente
l'episodio dove ho aggiunto anche i miei
amici quindi ci sono praticamente di
tutti
mangano del ruscello io sono rimasto
teso e sto giocando a scacchi con una
sedia contro una sedia vice e di a
fargli vedere chi sei
alla ragazzi parlando seriamente sabrina
e sasha sono qua dentro in questa casa
quale mentre federica che tra l'altro è
la ragazza che in questo uscendo con la
quale sta uscendo adesso teoricamente
sta in questa casa propria ma federica
to players e e hanno citofonato allo
stesso tempo perso 17 dollari o per
contro la sedia probabilmente vado
abbado vedere ok eccomi capi che ho
perso 17 simola ho incontrate sedia già
ti prego per cortesia ridarmeli cosa fai
ma basta non sai cucinare ma perché io
mio bella perché continuo a cucinare non
solo capace basta la consisterà magari
agli altrimenti addio mio la smetti di
cucinare hamburger che puzzano per
cortesia
guarda che c'è la gnocca de fori tumani
gli hamburger fai ridere fai ridere ora
cos'è che qui a questa è una tipa
bellissima voce
ma ci sono fuori casa vai a prendere
caneva sei scemo watt ma doni non sa se
infatti diceva dovesse ha scorazzato per
qassam è fuori ma non portare la bulgara
chiare ma io faccio schifo come persona
prendi il tuo cane sta li prendi per
cortesia same lo porti dentro per favore
ma l'onda lille hamburger
ehi ciao sei un cane se il mio cane
quindi se magari lo prendi il tuo cane
prendilo niente di amici offri amicizie
ma come un amicizia tieni e mio cane e
la mia famiglia che amicizia mio è mio
fratello è morto
no sta dormendo per terra allora in
tutto questo chi è questo qua non
toccarmi il cane ti ammazzo don lotario
mi dà fastidio la gente bisogno di
divertimento ma perchè non fai niente
entra in casa fa con il co siediti
siediti perché non interagisce con
ragazzi mi si è pagato il personaggio
sta fermo mi si è pagato il persone come
mai mi si paga il personaggio ogni tanto
dove vai some entra in casa per l'amor
di dio ti prego sto diventando sporco
lercio ti prego eccolo ce l'ha fatta si
è sbagliato ci ha messo una vita però si
è sbagliato mi sono fissato addosso
perfetto trendy calais prendi il cane
portalo in casa cribbio porta al cane
dentro metti siamo giunti chi è questa
che questa salma al fassi ciao salma
casa mia wish aspetti che c'è una tipa
presentazione in vita dentro chi è ma
chi sei ma è successo io sto gocciolando
dai bisogno di riparo da fuori questo
c'è chi è questa si sa dove sta a me sta
giocando questo giochino imposta
l'orario programmato ogni 12 che
qualcuno mi spiega cos'è successo a zia
ma che sei e che cos'è si è trasformata
in un corvo era un corpo questa te lo
giuro ma come era un corpo questa
guardano in vampiro ma sto male c'è un
bambino in casa mia scorta mi sun non
andare avanti non andare di là che c'è
un vampiro chiedi di andare via
no aspetta presentazioni partecipare che
mi mangia però io avere un bambino in
casa non ci tengono
non so che dire si parla della pioggia
hai visto che c'è la pioggia no mamma
mia che paura
condividi foto da photo si sta anche
faccio un sacco di like se facciamo
fatto come un vampiro vero sms che è
successo se smaterializzata la trippa e
lavano sono altri benvenuto nella
comunità e accidenti ma che bel collo
che hai che comunità o ma stata la larga
voi vampiri mangiava che è meglio same
tutto a posto
meno male che sta in casa il mio cane
che è ma sta qua vai a casa tua chili di
andare via vai via per cortesia vai via
di casa mia non ti voglio se un bambino
via via fuori allevato ho cambiato
maglia in tutto questo va bè summer
senti una roba c'è un vampiro fuori da
casa mia
chiede di andare a caccia al vampiro che
sta fuori da casa per fare perché la mia
casa infestata dai vampiri
io veramente paura ragazzi che siccome
sono stato scortese mi mangeranno di
notte non muoio vero no è una domanda
seria questa perché ci sto mettendo una
vita fare questo giocando seriamente mi
sto facendo un mazzo così
non voglio che mi ammazzino i compiti
per favore di casa nazista che non se
vuoi andare a casa cioè per passare
tempo assieme sono le sette quindi vuole
fare le cose e dopo cena però mi spiace
no devo dormire e dormire per me è
importante ragazzi ragazzi ragazzi cè un
papi ragazzi c'è un bambino che entro di
casa svegliati sveglia diciamo pero
ragazzi
no no no no no no no no vi aiuta ammazzo
ti ammazzo
raga cui sta facendo ragazzi non sta
succedendo
raga o no non mi ammazza resi noti prego
cosa succede aiutano perché no raga
ho fatto il pieno non riuscirei a dare
neanche un solo morso no sono morto non
sono morto non lo trasformerà in vampiro
ma lorenzo è talmente delizioso della
prossima volta ci vorrà davvero tanto
agio a tenermi a distanza tornerò quando
avrò voglia di uno spuntino di
mezzanotte raga perché come si ammazza
un vampiro paga mi ha succhiato tutto il
sangue ma sto pezzente manga mia ex
scrivetemi nei commenti come faccio se
lo sapete a far fuori i vampiri miss
incendiare la casa aiuto sapeva fuoco al
fuoco sava aiutami aiuto sono quasi
morto vi pare allora scusate mi si paga
il personaggio un vampiro tenta di farmi
fuori
mi va a fuoco la cucina o ma che giorni
sono questi
no ma io non ho parole veramente
successo di tutto ma un attimo invita
nell'otto attuale federica sanna o
perfetto abeba abeba avrebbe invitata
perché oggi il giorno dell'amore
festeggiamo un pochettino e ieri mi
dispiace non tocca gata scusami
dibattiti sull'esistenza dei vampiri ma
che dibattiti lo sa che esistono e mi
hanno quasi ma allora federiga lo so che
possiamo restavano ma ieri non ti ho
cagata perché un vampiro ha tentato di
uccidermi
e poi mi sono bloccato fuori da casa
riuscivo a muovermi e poi mi ha dato a
fuoco la cucina successo un po di cose
ieri un casino eccolo mi ha creduto
meno male da il regalo del giorno
dell'amore una rosa auricolari neri
macchina fotografica che siano le regali
neanche la mia ragazza effettivamente
quindi una rosa e siamo tirchi ma boni e
romantici piaciuta di giuda
da tanto ma dato che ha tirata fuori con
la roba lì ma scusami però comunque sono
contento sto soddisfando i miei desideri
romantici nel giorno delle terre card
sono l'amore dai diavoli degli
auricolari neri non è che puoi regalarmi
anche tu qualcosa e per sbaglio
faccio solo io non le è piaciuta ma la
pezza de schifo ho pagato adducendo euro
a da mela ma non ho capito il sacco
disordini prima a decifrare cosa stanno
dicendo ve lo dico ai ragazzi io nel
giorno dell'amore
vorrei dei libri non una macchina
fotografica perché sono spenti e volevo
prelati veli prima pioveva e poi si
rovinavano se di porto e piovani quindi
preferirei farti un caffè o guadagnato
224 dollari nel giorno libero
niente vorrei andare al bagno perché mi
sento mi sto facendo addosso
vai al bagno al bagno veloce ora devo
proprio andare va bene siamo federica è
stato un piacere
mamma mia ragazzi che fatica che fatica
a vivere sano sta dormendo some stata io
dovrei fare il bagno al mio cane perché
puzza la fa schifo sì ma non la vasca da
bagno mi hanno pagato a milioni di euro
si stanno scatenando alle rovine
attivati vieni a vedere certo rovine
antiche va evitata una festa wow rovine
antiche ma come mi sono vestito ma dai
provini antigua che stanno cosa succede
faccio una persona sola che balla poi a
martin garics raggiunto livello
superiore dell'abilità di canto vabbè
perché stavo cantan
lanci di coriandoli della festività
ragazzi sto cercando di socializzare
guardate come sono teso un estraneo un
pericolo ragazzi sono veramente io vi
giuro sono uguali alle feste e veramente
incredibile non sto scherzando sono
uguale alle feste identico ragazzi però
la domanda è ma quanto dura sta festa
che sono le tre di notte sono ancora
ballando in mezzo da solo tra l'altro
che triste sociali socializzare con
qualcuno e non sto riuscendo a
socializzare con nessuno sono le 4 del
mattino dove sto andando ragazzi la
festa è finita alcuni ballano ancora e
mattino è veramente tratto la location
di dove stanno facendo sta festa è
veramente incredibile valore ai location
incredibile mamma mia ragazzi che figata
pazzesca
vai a casa perfetto mai basta mi sono
rotto torna a casa e lorenzo è tornato a
casa
bene sono vivo e mattino ho fatto serata
o la maglia di moschino come ora voglia
di moschino veramente ma ci sono le
marche su the simpsons ham non avresti
mai voluto vedermi per la festa è stato
orribile
signori cresce ancora il monte fuji
perché per fare ambiente però che vi sia
piaciuto è fatto troppe cose in realtà
in questi episodi volevo parlare con
step fair e sabrina essa lascia solo che
li ho lasciati in casa loro non li ho
pagati perché sono successe troppe cose
quindi vediamo di pagarli nei prossimi
episodi da tim i consigli qua nei
commenti che io li seguo ditemi che cosa
volete che faccia con tutti quanti
organizza una festa
chi volete che mi innamori perché
federica ma bidonato stata brava ragazza
spero che video vi sia piaciuto come si
vive un momento mi piace iscrivetevi al
canale cliccata anche la campanellina
che vi arrivano le notifiche di quando
faccio i video e noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]